hub c'est l'onu qui proposait ce pacte
ce pacte qui dit on n'est pas
contraignant sauf que il ya des pays qui
n'ont pas signé
donc peut-être que finalement il est
plus contraignant que ce qu'on croit et
écouter à nouveau le point de vue de
marine le pen sur ce sujet alors
pourquoi les états unis ne l'ont pas
signée pourquoi israël ne l'a pas signée
pourquoi ça a fait tomber le
gouvernement belge
pourquoi tout cela s'il n'est pas
contraignant vous voyez bien que
évidemment on est là dans ce qu'on
appelle la soft law
vous savez la devise liberté égalité
fraternité elle n'est pas contraignante
non plus et pourtant il ya des juges qui
sont intégrées dans le droit
ce principe de fraternité notamment pour
permettre à monsieur héroux d'aidé
l'immigration clandestine
alors monsieur ayrault cédric héros
c'est un cetain un activiste qui
effectivement a été le passage de
migrants à la frontière française
et quand elle parle du gouvernement
belge qui est tombé marine le pen fait
allusion à la démission de charles
michel près ministre belge parce qu'à
une partie de la majorité qui l'a laissé
tomber la partie de droite voire
d'extrême droite parce que le
gouvernement belge avait signé ce ce
pack renaud girard c'est quoi votre
intime conviction il est contraignant où
il n'est pas contraignant ce pacte bien
le danger c'est qu'en fait on assistait
ce qu'on a cité des gens en france c'est
à dire que monsieur fabius qui était
devenu président du conseil
constitutionnel donc c'est un peu moins
important que les fonctions qu'il existe
qu'il exerçait avant mais il a décidé de
changer la loi lui tout seul c'est à
dire que il a aujourd'hui les citoyens
devaient respecter les lois de la
république y compris quand tommy glaçons
déplacement de la population et au
respect des frontières et là il a saisi
un mot de la devise républicaine
fraternité
liberté fraternité égalité
c'est en fait la fraternité c'est la
fatalité en soi les français et il
apprend la zouk et pour faire ce que
voulaient au départ dont je vous coupe
les parents voudraient pas tout à fait
répondu à ma question
ma question c'est est ce pacte à votre
avis est il qu'on s'installe et oui peut
le devenir peu de ses 5000 créé la cour
subjectivement s'est subrepticement ça
peut créer un nouveau droit de l'homme
qui serait le droit de l'homme
internationale de la migration j'ai le
droit de me grey quand je veux où je
veux où et où je veux parce que il pas
alors que ce n'est pas aujourd'hui dans
la déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme c'est les droits de l'homme
s'exerce à l'intérieur d'états
souverains membres des nations unies qui
ont ratifié cette déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme de
1948 donc cette action l'année sont très
petits ce qui peut faire léman et puis
c'est un pack cimer lisez ici qui
culpabilise des plaisirs irish est qui
et qui exonère un peu les débats voilà
je vous coupe la parole pour pouvoir la
distribuer et la passer à un autre
confrère du figaro si vous voulez bien
dans un dans un pour un court moment
c'est edouard de maréchal qui explique
que sur le plateau de feugarolles avec
ce matin quel est l'esprit quelle est la
philosophie de ce pacte pour
l'immigration et considérée comme
quelque chose de positif encore une fois
quelque chose d'inéluctable
et surtout elle est considérée dans son
acceptation anglo saxon c'est à dire une
forcément multiculturelle c'est à dire
que le
le migrant doit évidemment respecter la
culture de son pays d'accueil
mais le pays d'accueil doit aussi se
doit aussi respecter et se conformer à
la culture du de la personne qui arrive
sur son pays c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut à ce point une vision
anglo-saxonne multiculturaliste de
l'immigration qui ne correspond pas
nécessairement à à l'acceptation de
beaucoup d'autres états dans le monde
on pose la question selon vous le pacte
sur l'immigration risque-t-il d'être une
bombe à retardement pour ses signataires
vous êtes 72 % à considérer que oui
ferghana ziari quel est votre point de
vue là dessus est ce que finalement ce
pacte sais pas si symbolique que ce
qu'on imagine
oui je pense qu'avec ce que nous ont dit
le gouvernement français je pense qu'il
ya quand même eu une petite bulle
médiatique là dessus c'est à dire c'est
un texte qui a essentiellement une
portée déclaratoire et ça n'ira pas plus
loin que ça
à mon grand regret limites parce que
voici moi je considère que la libre
circulation est un droit de l'homme et
c'était pas un nouveau droit je pense
que les politiques migratoires
historiquement ça ne va pas de soi c'est
à dire que jusqu'à la fin du dix
neuvième siècle n'avait quasiment pas et
c'est seulement avec la première guerre
mondiale qu'on a commencé à émettre des
passeports à restreindre les mouvements
de personnes et il ya eu tout au long du
xxème siècle des de multiples tentatives
de multiples conférences internationales
pour tenter et bien d'assouplir les
restrictions migratoires donc à mon sens
bien ça oui moi je pense que la
circulation je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
si la question que vous posez c'est qui
aujourd'hui est légitime à définir des
critères de sélection d'admission et
d'exclusion moi en tant que libéral je
considère que la politique migratoire
des décentralisée c'est à dire que si
demain un propriétaire veut louer son
logement si demain un entrepreneur veut
embaucher un travailleur de je ne sais
quelle nationalité il n'a pas de compte
à rendre à qui que ce soit sur qui leur
embauche est dommage de revivre à
shanghai le gouvernement chinois ne doit
pas pouvoir m'aider alors pour - oui
pour moi c'est une atteinte
effectivement la libre circulation donc
il n'est pas contraignant donc je pense
qu'on a beaucoup enfin aujourd'hui on a
context effectivement avec l'émergence
des populismes avec la peur des dés avec
la peur d'une peur ambiante de
l'immigration effectivement tous les
gouvernements
bien évident parce que même si c'est un
texte n'a comporté déclaratoire avec des
grandes entreprises
vivre en entreprise
bon c'est pas juste un gouvernement
mondial puisqu'en fait saluera rien les
règles et les normes l'état elles sont
effectivement réprimer les activités
criminelles
mais pour moi la libre circulation pas
circuler ni drainé pas d'un acte
criminel donc moi je ne suis pas du tout
dans cette perspective qui consiste à
criminaliser criminels simplement est ce
que les chinois vous a le droit ou pas
devenir nom renaud girard nous voulons
pas d'eux - shanghai légitimant c'est à
dire ça pour revenir au coeur du sujet à
alexis lacroix jeu je pense qu'il a une
légitimité de telles lois d'hyères nom
renaud girard vont rester en france nous
n'avons aucun droit venez vous installer
avec votre famille à frais engagés
s'interrogerait sexy c'est là si on peut
revenir quand même au pacte de marrakech
qui nous occupe mon sentiment mais je
dis que c'est un sentiment sur la base
de ce qu'est ce texte à dire
quarante et une page à peu près
contenant 23 objectif pour rendre ce
contrat pour objectif c'est vrai pour
rendre les migrations planétaire à la
fois plus sécurisé et plus juste et plus
humaine
en gros c'est ça mon sentiment c'est que
c'est un texte qui effectivement comme
le dit ferghana d'abord une valeur
déclaratoire c'est comme une sorte de
loi morale qu'ancienne au dessus de la
tête de l'ensemble des gouvernants mais
ça ne va pas se substituer au droit
positif de leur pays donc ça c'est ce
qu'il fera pelé mais mon autre sentiment
hélas je suis plus inquiet que feria on
sait que effectivement à la faveur des
fêtes news
à la faveur de l'exploitation par
certains réseaux sociaux qui fonctionne
très bien dans le camp libéral un salesi
libéraux ils savent peut-être pas bâtir
des états ils savent encore moins sans
doute bâtir de la solidarité durable
mais sa part compte diffuser des
saloperies savent très bien le faire ils
le font avec une redoutable efficacité
il me semble que ce texte assez anodin
en réalité qui résume très bien l'esprit
de l'onu d'aujourd'hui
ce texte est en train de devenir
le mauvais objet de la propagande
extrême droitière internationale et ça
c'est ça c'est auprès préoccupant parce
qu'effectivement ça veut dire que dans
les semaines les mois qui viennent il
peut devenir un abcès de fixation
extraordinaire et d'ailleurs on a vu
certains gilet jaune dans leur folie
complotistes commencé à s'exciter contre
ce pacte de marrakech comme s'il avait
force de loi en fallait y va pas fort se
voit enfin il faut le dire il est pas
comme quand le pacte de marrakech dit
que l'état devrait arrêter de soutenir
financièrement les médias qui sont
opposés à l'immigration mais également
sur pop écoutez qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut pas dire que les médias qui
d'abord ça ne veut pas bien je crois dit
c'est pas écrit aussi à l'émergence est
écrit et xénophobes et naturellement
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire termine
sans remettre en cause la liberté de la
presse voilà c'est écrit ce n'était pas
évident mais attendez les médias
xénophobe oui pourquoi effectivement
mais sincèrement parlons-en sincèrement
pourquoi l'état devrait il se sentir
obligé de financer des sites xénophobe
il ne le fait signe non mais franchement
il ne le fait pas qu'est ce que cette
tendance et c'est tant mieux moi je
l'assemblée générale avait mené général
les 190 brésil on line renaud raison des
coûts maintenant pour la faire il doit
se faire au juge alt et peu importe on
d'affaires aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble
de l'europe ces transnationales là
inoffensifs des populistes et des
libéraux sur le plan culturel pour nous
persuader que tout ce qui facilite les
migrations détruit les états il faut
répondre à ces gens que c'est faux et
que le pacte de marrakech n'est pas le
cheval de troie d'imaginer conjoint on
voit on voit quand on voit qu'on
angleterre par exemple l'immigration a
considérablement consolidé consolidé
l'angleterre au pouvoir etc si je vais
passer la parole à ses fins de marchands
qui aura même le mot de la fin sur ce
sujet mais pas avant de l'avoir donné à
nos internautes
alors qui ce qui s'indignent eux du fait
qu'on n'ait pas demandé leur avis aux
français et là on nous dit signer ce
pacte contre la volonté des français
scandaleux il est inadmissible que le
parlement n'ait pas été consultée ajoute
anti mac tandis que brawn ito considère
lui que le pacte signé ne peut en aucun
cas passer au dessus des lois françaises
ce qui est vrai c'est que
pour reprendre ce que disait rené girard
quand on a mis la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen dans la
constitution
on a dit assez que le préambule ça n'a
pas de valeur juridique contraignante et
finalement ça en a une
avec la décision du conseil
constitutionnel notamment lors de la
dernière épisode avec laurent fabius
comme vous le rappeliez mais je vous
passe la parole lors je regrette que
pour commenter cette question en effet
pour la deuxième fois dans cette
émission appel à marine le pen il y à
d'autres responsables politiques dans ce
pays qui s'y opposent qui s'y opposent
qui ont quelque chose à dire sur le
sujet j'aimerais que l'on présente des
gens qui ont des choses positives à dire
sur le sujet moi je suis en faveur de
l'immigration
l'immigration est une chance et le
psychodrame ridicule ridicule qui a lieu
en france en ce moment reflète le
malaise français avant tout il en dit
beaucoup plus sur nous que sur l'immense
population qui nous entoure deuxième
chose
ce pacte est clairement non contraignant
il est non contraignant comme le pape de
paris sur la côte 24 sur le climat et
malheureusement ils risquent donc de de
s'enliser dans le sable c'est ça le
risque que nous courons avec ce pas mais
attention à ne pas constamment mettre en
lumière les déclarations de l'extrême
droite
alors question je vais juste le point
factuel pourquoi marine le pen parce
qu'en fait on a une règle dans cette
émission c'est que on prend toujours les
réactions des politiques est plus
récente et la dernière personne à s'être
exprimé sur ce sujet c'était marine le
pen ce matin sur rtl
voilà pourquoi nous l'avons ne l'avons
fait parler ça m'intéresse le thème de
l'immigration est une chance et du
multiculturalisme
alors la question qu'on peut poser d
abord temps distinctes enfin
l'immigration par exemple en france a
produit beaucoup de musique de
multiculturalisme puisque
je parle dans les années récentes je
parle pas de l'immigration polonaise
italienne mais nation chrétienne je
parle je parle des années récentes d'été
prof 40 des personnes ça crée beaucoup
de multiculturalisme
j'ai pas l'impression que ça marche très
bien et j'ai pas l'impression que ça
marche très bien
ni en france ni en belgique ni en
allemagne ni en effet j'ai pas de raison
que ça marche et simplement il ya une
autre chose
je pense que l'immigration légale tout à
fait d'accord avec simplement un débat
en disant si bien veux-t-on d'immigrés
est et d'où doivent venir
doivent-ils venir de guinée doivent-ils
venir de l'afrique du sud ouest médias
hier 2 voilà exactement est un vrai
débat un vrai parlement canadien
évidemment nous avons fait beaucoup de
léran arrive chez nous on ne refait pas
comme dans la politique migratoire de la
france aujourd'hui même si c'est un
sujet passionnant il nous reste quelques
minutes pour parler d'un dernier thème
celui d'aider gilet jaune des gilets
jaunes réunis sur un rond point dans la
périphérie de châtellerault ont incendié
une oeuvre qui s'appelle la main jour
d'une oeuvre d'un français